-We have a great show tonight.
You know, the holiday spirit
is really all around us,
and especially here in New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, Jimmy?
Sorry, do you have a second?
-Oh, yeah.
Hey, Lea Michele.
Yeah, what's up?
-I'm just trying to get
the Wi-Fi password.
[ Light laughter ]
-You want the Wi-Fi password?
-Yeah, you know, Wi-Fi password.
It's like the Internet
that comes through the air?
Wi-Fi.
-No, I know what Wi-Fi is.
I'm just a little bit busy
right now.
I'm just in the middle
of doing the show.
-Oh, my gosh.
I -- I had no idea.
I had no idea.
This is --
This is so embarrassing.
-It's Okay, Lea.
Its no big deal.
-No! It's a big deal.
I've ruined the entire show.
-You haven't ruined the show.
I mean, just go back
to your dressing room.
We'll get you the Wi-Fi.
-Okay.
♪♪
♪ Oh, what have I done? ♪
♪ What was I thinking? ♪
♪ I wanted Wi-Fi,
so I went out on stage ♪
♪ I'm such a fool ♪
♪ I'm out of the business ♪
♪ Yes, it's time to part ways ♪
♪ Guess I'll have to do plays ♪
♪ I'm out of the business ♪
-No, stop, stop, stop!
Whoa, Lea, Lea. Stop. Stop.
You're not out of the business.
You just --
Just go backstage, relax.
I'll get the show back on track,
and we'll let you know
when it's time for you
and Jonathan Groff.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Hey, Jimmy.
[ cheers and applause ]
-No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
It's Jonathan Groff.
No, Jonathan.
I was just saying your name.
It doesn't mean that you're
supposed to come out here.
-Oh.
I didn't actually
hear you say my name.
I was just wondering if you knew
where the bathroom is.
[ Laughter ]
Is it that bucket backstage?
-What? No!
-Of course not, yes.
Unrelated, just don't look
in that bucket, please.
So what's going on out here?
-I'm in the middle of the show.
-Oh, my God.
You're in the middle
of a taping?
-Yeah.
-I believe this.
I have just completely
ruined your show.
-No, you haven't ruined
the show. It's fine.
Just go backstage,
and I'll call you out later.
-[ Sighs ]
♪♪
♪ What have I done? ♪
♪ What was I thinking? ♪
♪ Nature called, so I answered ♪
♪ And now nobody will
answer my calls ♪
♪ I'm out of the business ♪
♪ No more champagne or cigars ♪
♪ Guess I'll do on
"Dancing With the Stars" ♪
♪ I'm out of the business ♪
-No, no, no.
Please, please, please.
Stop! Jonathan, stop.
Everyone stop.
Neither of you are
out of the business.
It's all fine.
Can you please just go and wait
until it's your time
to come out.
-Sure. sure, sure.
Sure, Jimmy.
-Sorry, sir.
-Yeah.
Sorry.
♪♪
-♪ What have I done? ♪
♪ What was I thinking? ♪
♪ I was rude to my guests ♪
♪ That's not how a host
should behave ♪
♪ I'm out of the business ♪
♪ What have I done? ♪
-Jimmy, wait!
-Oh, my gosh.
It's 8-year-old me from --
sent from the past.
Did you come to remind me
why I got into the business
in the first place?
-And that you should always
fight to fulfill your dreams.
-And that second chances
are always possible,
no matter what you may
or may not have done
inside of a bucket?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
I'm the president
of the network's kid.
My dad's busy green-lighting
"Minions 8,"
but he wanted me to tell you...
♪ You're out of the business ♪
♪ Time to leave Hollywood ♪
♪ I get to host now ♪
♪ My dad said I could ♪
-♪ He is our host now ♪
♪ His dad said he could ♪
-♪ Bring me some water ♪
♪ And some candy and snacks ♪
♪ And don't change the channel ♪
-♪ Because we will
be right back ♪
[ Cheers and applause]